and I
with everything that's been happening
with Halo I I was still confident that
you know the idea that you know Bonnie
stepped down and there was just this
seemed like a willingness to take a
Fresh Approach to step back from what
they have try to make that as try to
make that product as as good a product
as it possibly can be and maybe move
forward kind of a clean slate something
that 343 really hasn't had like 343 even
ever since they took over Halo they're
still sort of in the shadow of Bungie
right and you know whether it's them
taking the single player in a different
direction people not being necessarily
overly happy with that them kind of
being hit or miss with multiplayer like
one game has great multiplayer one game
has a well-regarded single player and
vice versa they were never ever really
able to put it together I think infinite
was the first time that considering the
product that we got overall people would
happen with both aspects of that